محمد هون هون
محمد حي يرزق اخيرا ابصر النورة بعد اكثر
من 100 ساعه تحت الركب
[موسيقى]
يسالوا عن جده ويطمئن قلبه قبل ان يلتقي
في سياره الاسعاف اخاه يوسف الذي نجحوا
ايضا النهايه السعيده لكابوس الاثنين
الماضي استثناء في كارثه زلزال هو الاسوا
في تركيا وسوريا منذ عام 39 من القرن
الماضي الامل في العثور على احياء تحت
الكتل الخرسانيه في المناطق المنكوبه
يقابله رقم مرعب لعدد القتلى الذي تجاوز
20 الف لم تنتشر كل الجثث ورفع الانقاض
سيستغرق وقتا طويلا
سيكون اطول في المناطق السوريه التي تفتقر
الى المعدات اللازمه وفرق الانقاذ بالعدد
المطلوب لمواجهه الماساه على اطلال
المباني سلاسل بشريه تعمل ضد الياس
والظروف المناخيه الصعبه لا يهون على عمال
الانقاص ومثل هذه اللحظات الاقرب الى
المعجزه عندما يكتب عمر جديد للرضيع او
طفل او اي ناج بعد ايام بين الموت والحياه
مهما كانت خبره بعض عمل الانقاذ ثمه لحظه
لا يمكن فيها مقاومه البكاء
لحظه الاصعب هي هذه عندما تدفن ام ابنتها
او جده حفيدتها حداد اديمان مفتوح كباقي
المناطق المنكوبه جنازات لا تنتهي واحزان
سيعيش معها هل الضحايا مدى الحياه
مقبره جماعيه في جبلب اللاذقيه عائلات
باكملها لم تعد موجوده سوى على شواهد
القبور وفي قلوب ذويها الاف السوريين
ماتوا في زلزال زاد جرحا عميقا في بلد
ينزف منذ سنوات في بلد اللجوء ليجد بعضهم
سوى الحدائق العامه للبقاء فيها الى اشعار
اخر هذا حالهم في غاز عنتاب وعدوا بخيم لم
تصل وبمساعده تاخرت
يا ربي بقلوب يعتصرها الالم تعلو
التكبيرات والدعوات في مدينه كهرمان مراش
اختفى جزء كبير من عمران المدينه ومن فيها
بفعل الزلزال حضر المصلون في جمعه تكررت
فيها الدعوه عبر اسقاع المعموره بالرحمه
للضحايا تمر ايام الانتظار المر على البعض
اقصى طموحهم العصور على جثه قريبا لاكرامه
ليلا ونهارا تحفر سواعد الالاف وسط الخراب
بحثا عن احياء واموات قال احد المسعفين
انها الساعات الاخيره ونعمل بالسرعه نحاول
ان ندرك الاحياء في الرمق الاخير